Анатолій Артеменко обробляє цю землю відколи розпався Радянський Союз.
Його бізнес переживав злети і падіння, але ніщо так не вдарило
по ньому, як ця війна та російська блокада Чорного моря.
Чоловік каже, що врожай зернових і насіння цього літа був
фантастичним. І не тільки для нього: за оцінками міністерства
сільського господарства України, країна виробить близько 60 мільйонів тонн зерна.
Та фермеру вдалося вивезти лише 10 відсотків зі своїх складів.
Решта – поки залишається тут.
Ми любуємося і показуємо, що дійсно це зерно, яке годує весь світ.
Україна прогодує, мабуть, 20% усього світу. Дуже багато в Україні зерна.
От вам це зерно, яке, мабуть, і всі країни, особливо
на африканському континенті, всі чекають цього хліба, цього нашого зерна.
А ми його не можемо вивезти. Дуже прикро.
Своє зерно та насіння Анатолій відправляв по шосе
в одеський чорноморський порт. Тепер він відправляє вантажівку
в інший бік. Найкращий варіант зараз – південно-західний шлях через Дунай.
Щоб уникнути російської загрози, Україна спрямовує
більшу частину свого експорту до невеликих портів на річці Дунай
на своєму західному кордоні. Звідти більшість вантажів прямують
не вгору за течією до Європи, а вниз за течією у води ЄС Чорного моря,
де вони теоретично захищені від нападів Росії.
Ця вузька сільська дорога тепер є найважливішим торговим
коридором України. І зараз вона переповнена.
Найгірше – це простої, що ми стоїмо, як склади на колесах.
Довго чекаємо на вивантаженні – де прийде судно, де не прийде.
Буває тижнями тут живемо.
Маленьке портове містечко Рені зараз несе історичну
відповідальність за порятунок ринку зерна України.
І це зробило його мішенню для Росії.
Знімати в порту Рені суворо заборонено, та я хочу показати вам,
як близько до Румунії через річку Дунай. Хороший плавець міг би
перепливти річку всього за 15 хвилин.
І багато хто вважав, що Росія не наважиться бомбардувати порт
за кілька сотень метрів від країни-члена НАТО.
Та росіяни атакували порт дронами Shahed рано-вранці 24 липня.
Ці безпілотники знищили портову інфраструктуру, в тому числі склад,
повний зерна. Приблизно через тиждень Росія атакувала
інший склад зерна всього за 70 км на схід звідси - в Ізмаїлі.
Дмитро Голубєв керує невеликою судноплавною компанією
та має в районі зернові склади. Перенаправлення торгівлі через Дунай
принесло йому додатковий бізнес, але разом з тим і серйозний ризик.
Запитуємо його, чи хвилювався він через останній напад.
За майно – ні, а за людей – так. Ми, звичайно, дуже хвилювалися,
тому що під час атаки були наші люди в порту – як у ренійському,
так і в ізмаїльському. За людей ми дуже сильно хвилювалися.
А за майно? Яке майно? Людське життя безцінне.
Українські вантажовідправники, такі як Голубєв, можуть бути готові
протистояти російській загрозі. Але багато іноземних суден,
призначених для збору зерна, більш обережні.
Через вторгнення Об'єднаний військовий комітет Ллойда оголосив
регіон зоною військових ризиків. Це означає, що кораблі платитимуть
премію додатково до своїх звичайних витрат на страхування.
Сума відрізняється в залежності від того, хто ваші брокери,
у кого ви страхуєтеся, але це збільшило вартість доставки в регіоні.
Звичайно, важливо зазначити, що на північ від 45 – лінії від заходу Севастополя
- наразі страхування не пропонується, хоча ми розуміємо,
що деякі страховики розглядають цей варіант, щоб судна могли
використовувати тимчасовий коридор, який Україна оголосила
до трьох портів, які були раніше в Чорноморській зерновій ініціативі.
Фактична блокада Росією чорноморських портів України пригнічує
експорт зерна та насіння. Тому ціна, яку українські фермери
отримують від трейдерів за свою продукцію, впала до болючого мінімуму в липні,
коли Росія вийшла з укладеної за посередництва ООН угоди,
яка дозволяла морський експорт сільськогосподарської
продукції з України через Чорне море.
Тож тепер менш ніж за тридцять кілометрів від південно-східної лінії фронту
сільські фермери, чий бізнес ледь пережив російські ракети,
бояться ще небезпечнішого ворога: найнижчих цін на їхній урожай.
Це будувалося більше 20 років. За один день воно розбите.
Питання: чи закинути цю справу, чи може спробувати таки втриматися?
У цьому році так само прибутку не буде ніякого.
З такими складськими приміщеннями, з усім, з такою ціною
в нас прибутків не буде. Це тільки щоб втриматися,
віддати людям належне – пайщикам.
Оце залишки ракети, які до нас прилітають.
Урожай зібрали зернових ранніх: пшениці, ячмінь скошений.
Завезли в склад, який не добитий. Зберігаємо.
Ціна поки що не дуже прийнятна для аграріїв, тому позберігаємо,
подивимося, що буде далі. Щоб відновлювати – потрібні кошти.
А при цій ціні на наше збіжжя - це нереально відновлювати її.
Російські атаки на зернові склади та порти становлять серйозний виклик
для українських експортерів зерна. Багато країн глобального півдня
залежать від цього експорту, щоб прогодувати своїх людей,
тоді як Україні вони потрібні, щоб зберегти свою економіку.
У Росії добре організовані ВМС (військово-морські сили) в цьому регіоні.
Україна має лише сили берегової оборони.
Тож Росія використовує свою здатність контролювати море
далі від узбережжя України, щоб спробувати заблокувати Україну.
Це економічна стратегія відсічення.
Вони намагаються зруйнувати ті види господарської діяльності,
які ще приносять дохід в Україну: виробництво електроенергії,
а тепер і виробництво сільськогосподарської продукції,
зокрема зерна та кукурудзи.
Та Україна вже почала відправляти кораблі через Чорне море
тимчасовим  гуманітарним коридором – щоб цивільні судна
могли вийти з українських портів. Перше судно вийшло з Одеси
в середу вранці з невідомим вантажем.
Контейнеровоз під прапором Гонконгу – один із багатьох,
які застрягли в українських портах з початку війни.
Та військова загроза з боку РФ зберігається.
Це дуже важливий момент, що Україна намагається
протистояти російській загрозі потопити або атакувати ці кораблі.
І це дуже важливий знак також з точки зору гуманітарного фактора,
оскільки цей корабель застряг в Україні з минулого року,
відколи почалася повномасштабна війна. Тому все це дипломатично
і стратегічно дуже важливо.
А в міноборони України попередили, що з 21 липня цього року
всі судна РФ, які прямують в акваторії Чорного моря,
вважатимуться Україною як такі, що перевозять вантажі
воєнного призначення - з усіма відповідними ризиками.